enorme columna blindada que no avanza
como se esperaba y helicópteros
derribados en pleno vuelo está la fuerza
invasora de vladimir putin en problemas
preguntas que se están haciendo sobre el
cuerpo militar de putin estás imágenes
grabadas por soldados ucranianos
muestran armamento ruso abandonado
dañado o sin combustible los informes
dicen que algunas tropas rusas incluso
se comunican en frecuencia de radios
civiles no seguras sin embargo estos
contratiempos logísticos no son
suficientes para sugerir que las fuerzas
rusas están al borde de la derrota el
ejército ruso tiene problemas con
algunos equipos pero es muy fuerte en
términos de artillería aunque gran parte
de esa artillería ya ha sido destruida
entre los 900 mil soldados alistados en
el ejército ruso
muchos son muy jóvenes y no tienen
experiencia de combate la moral de
muchos de ellos parece estar decayendo
llevan tres días diciéndonos que vienen
por nosotros pero nadie hace nada dicen
que sus superiores los han dejado en
medio de la nada sin armas pesadas ni
artillería mira dónde estamos durmiendo
nuestras botas están empapadas no
sabemos qué hacer también hay
interrogantes sobre la estrategia
militar de rusia las fuerzas armadas
ucranianas tienen equipos modernos
proporcionados en su mayoría por los
eeuu entonces fue un error enviar
decenas de miles de vehículos blindados
vemos fotos de la enorme columna
blindada no es muy práctica parece una
fuerza bastante voluminosa no
especialmente ágil
de móvil el viernes putin dijo que
pagaría a mercenarios de siria y medio
oriente para que lucharan por él en
ucrania queda por ver si se trata sólo
de una amenaza o de una señal real de
que su ejército tiene problemas